hi prospective student my name is
sebastian van and welcome to our surf
diving
we program today I'm here to answer some
of your questions for this program and
hope can entice you to apply for
admissions because one of the most
amazing things you've ever built here at
Udacity I have a list of questions here
submitted for various students the first
was by Michael and the question is for
those coming from non tech backgrounds
but trying to break into the field but I
think the best way they can stand out to
a potential employer first of all you
should know the valley is burning for
more talent in this field it's actually
amazing how many companies have worked
in this field from Intel and NVIDIA and
Auto and uber and Google and many other
companies and there's just a huge
shortage of people and the reason why
there's a shortage is no one teaches
self-driving cars universities totally
teach stuff I mean cars gonna take them
a decade to catch up so if you can and
the only ones Udacity is not the biggest
serve driving car educator in the world
at this point already and you can join
us and be allocated with us even I ran
the Google team and we hired people what
was always great as a good technical
skill and go to academic skill of course
which you can get here at Udacity if you
want but also a portfolio of interesting
things you've done and one of the
distinguishing factors of a Udacity
program of our university program is we
very much project focus there's lots of
projects where you build something and
what you build is something and show to
the potential employer and employers
more and more pay attention to what
you've actually built so you do deep
learning you do sensor fusion you do
localization path planning controls and
these are the things that employers
directly want to see implement on their
cars in fact to be quite truthful if you
do deep learning these days in Silicon
Valley
you should really find a job very easily
because it's such a hot field today and
there's so few people who understand it
so to stand out to answer your question
Michael to stand out I'd say take the
program build your portfolio and then
work with our careers team to make sure
that your product portfolio is very
curated and your CV looks great and we
will do our very best to help you find a
job second question is from beeper I
think from India I assume because the
question says what are the career
prospects for students of developing
countries like India where there's no
self-driving car industry
yet so it turns out there's a car
industry in India as well in China
there's on a Brazil one in France in
Europe and all these companies
eventually have to go into this field so
I know from China in particular the
companies are desperately hiring in this
space right now and it might not be
quite as flashy as the way Mo's and and
the Nvidia's in the world or the
Mercedes but typically what happens in
the world is that Silicon Valley leads
the way and hires first and then
companies around the world hire similar
talent so we've been working with
companies around the world placing
people in this field and I would say
even though there isn't quite industry
yet you always want to kind of get
educated today for the job of tomorrow
not today for the role of today or the
table of yesterday this is something
it's rapidly growing with enormous
demand around the world so I would
suggest do it and try it and quite
frankly even if you can't find a job in
the self-driving car industry there's
not so many robotics companies and
industries around sensor fusion and
Internet of Things deevak has similar
skills that I bet you can leverage the
skills at two adjacent fields you will
be in demand as migration do you really
ask the question what are the key
unsolved challenges and the term is
driving today that holds us back from
getting from level 4 tana me to never
fire but what I mean for those who don't
know this never five is the one day I
can just fall asleep and wake up two
hours later and still be a life with
level four it still requires some
occasional human intervention
let me five is a dream of course of what
we're doing it's the Holy Grail and and
quite frankly we're not there yet which
means you can make you can as a student
you can make the difference come to our
Nanna we enroll learn the skills and
change the world I am jealous because
when I started self-driving cars there
was another degree program I had to
teach myself now you can get a much
accelerated path in your life for
joining us but here the unresolved
challenges the real difficulty in
surviving cars is this long long long
tail of unlikely things it's like the
couch on the highway it's the mattress
it's the deer that crosses the road it's
a flat tire that you are into
unexpectedly and in totality every if
even every every year you as a human
driver Express exactly one
sings then it couldn't be level-5
autonomy because he can't have an
excellent every year so we have to get
to this point we are these very very
unlikely things are still being handled
responsibly the good thing is our cars
are becoming better and better every
year and as we drive more and more we
get more and more examples of these very
very unlikely things and we can knock
them off and with the advent of deep
learning and machine learning the speed
at which were able to knock them off has
actually massively increased so the nice
thing about computers is the more data
you accumulate the more you can knock
off and unlike human brains when we pass
away and our kids take over they have to
learn everything on scratch again in
computer land you can just keep the data
and pass it on to the next generation of
cars so so even the unborn future cars
can benefit from today's experiments
having said this we need more people
like yourself to join in this we need
smart people dedicated people who are
willing to go the extra mile learn the
skills and then build bigger data sets
and leverage more machine learning to
get to this point because then we get to
this point and we have a level-five
economy it's gonna be a complete
game-changer for the world that means we
can share cars in a new way the car
could come to us empty pick us up go
somewhere else that means our downturn
errors will have no parking spaces
anymore because all the cars are just
busy driving people around
it also means transport will be safer we
were gonna probably save a million lives
over here
and be much much more affordable to
people so that's the vision of why we're
doing this Marco's is asking the
question were the biggest market for
software developers for Thomas driving
and who are the phonology ADA's I mean
every person is knows way more on Google
as the leader in this field there is a
whole bunch of great OMS who've really
pushed hard and have amazing technology
must say this is one of our hiring
partners BMW Toyota Ford General Motors
around the world companies Nissan are
now gearing up and making enormous
progress hand in hand with those our
Tier one suppliers which I think
companies don't talk that much about but
they do amazing work Bosch and and
Continental Delphi and many others we
just saw mobile eye being sold in
Therese
the supplier there's enormous progress
and there's chip companies like Nvidia
into that push the same boundary and
have made this a strategic goal in fact
I can tell you it in vineya one of our
other hiring partners surviving car is
one of the most important corporate
goals and then really interesting for me
is ride sharing companies as you know we
have a competition with Diddy right now
running four hundred thousand dollars to
build self-driving car technology Diddy
is the world's largest rideshare company
much larger than over but even inside
the United States
Uber's ATP is working with audacity as a
hiring partner and and of course lift
our companies that really understand if
someone invented a level five
self-driving car it will be completely
disruptive to the business so they have
all prioritized self-driving as a number
one strategic objective for their
company and it's really important if you
look at recent acquisitions in space
from cruise being sold to GM or auto
being sold to over you can just by the
magnitude of dollar amounts really read
of how desperate and how the industry is
to make progress in this field it's a
big race it's like the race of the moon
the rates of the self-driving car so if
you come and join us and take your time
in and made to involved and apply and
and and finish your studies and and get
an army certificate then I my suspicion
is he won't have a hard time finding a
job matt is asking a question here's the
question however the proteins and skills
developed in the south of in cardinal
agree transfer to roles in robotics and
automation quite quite well so if we
look at the core things we're covering
deep learning sensor fusion localization
and mapping controls and path planning
and systems integration these are the
the core project areas these topics
apply to anything robotic and and even
beyond robotics if you go to smart
buildings Internet of Things variable
devices devices equipped with sensors
biomedical devices hardware monitor
force intelligent hospitals the
commonality of these is that you have a
flood of read about sensor data coming
in it has to be processed and then
decisions have to be made based on
data and that's what self-driving cars
all about now I don't think if you
wanted to general robotics we have other
than degrees at Udacity that might be a
better fit because this one is specific
to cars so you will learn and implement
things on a car platform evoke with the
car simulator we have a physical car
Udacity by the very end you get a chance
to run your software on those physical
cars which is very cool but the general
skill set AI controls and so on is very
broadly applicable and we live in a
world where now where I think physical
intelligent devices will become the next
big revolution across many many
industries so if you and all this can't
know that we it's primarily for
surviving cars but I think the skills
can be leveraged into many other fields
Marco's is asking interesting question
here which is close to my heart how much
of the problem in this case after in
cars do you think can be solved with
machine learning in which parts rely on
systems engineering based on manually
crafted decision making now it when I
grew up there was no machine learning
really of any scale and software
engineer would write on this very
meticulous kitchen recipe often millions
of lines of code for every possible
contingency I would argue the single
biggest innovation in computer science
in recent history has been the effort of
scalable machine learning but now at the
point where a well-trained machine
learning system can replace human the
mythologists and fighting skin cancer or
can play go better than the best human
player and it's a matter of scale and to
me this really means we're flipping from
a world where a human engineer has to
handcraft
every rule to a world where we can teach
a machine and the Machine finds his own
rules
so the Machine becomes own programmer so
to speak there's of course not a binary
switch we still have to architect a lot
but as time goes on I think we're going
to rely more and more on data science
and machine learning and experiential
learning for the machines to find their
own rules as this transition occurs our
machines to be infinitely more competent
if you look at the recent progress in
computer science from the way and no
lawyers work in terms of using the
average machine learning to find legal
documents or doctors work in radiology
to
chest x-rays to understand whether
that's a cancer or not these things are
now more and more empowered by machine
learning and as this progresses the
capability of these machines has really
exploded in a very positive way so I
would say to your question it's not a
binary question we still have the
architect but over time the machine
learning component would be more and
more important Jesse who was asking
question what's evolved academia going
forward for Thomas vehicles I'll be
careful not to i-i've said my my friends
from Stanford and Carnegie Mellon but
the reality is at this point the major
progress in self-driving cars has
actually become income from industry and
the reason is I mean I ran the Google
team for many years and we were afforded
a level of freedom and a level of scale
at Google that I was never able to
master at Stanford when you look at
education right now I would actually
argue not as only as this program the
self-driving car program at audacity the
world's largest pros are self-driving
cars effect we train more students right
now then all universities combined but
we also benefit from our close corporate
partners like Mercedes and BMW that
video many others who helped us build
this curriculum to make it Vinnie kind
of bleeding-edge we we are so incredibly
in front of everybody else because we
can pay this curriculum much faster than
universities can of course universities
are great places like teach at stem for
myself how do you recommend them but if
you want to have the latest skills on
surviving cars I would argue this non
degree program that's the place to be
okay here's a student named Otto not to
be confused with the startup company of
the same name and he's asking when an
open-source self-driving cars to ever be
as prevalent as Linux boy possibly I
mean obviously if he doesn't be building
one and there's several others now who
build open stopped by two just announced
it and there's another startup in San
Francisco which is on our partners coma
AI is also working on it Linux is
incredibly prevalent and it's been
around and it's been vastly used I I
would be careful to think of it as quite
as prevalent this may be at some point
impactful yes
because we lose something like a million
people every year on public streets and
traffic accidents and I think if you're
able to bring self-driving cars in order
to every car you could conceivably cut
this number down to like ten or five
percent of what it is today
so I think that's important these are
the early days we don't quite know how
the industry will shake out will weigh
more take everything over by the fact
that they are technologically superior
right now and licenses to car companies
or of an open-source tech Android like
win in the end of a day really depends
how the various players are playing
their cards but that's the fun part
that's the reason why you should be in
the program right now because it's early
and you can influence these paths by
what way I won't broken and helping us
building a better open source repository
yet he does it he so enroll or apply and
then help us build the world's best
technology it's up to you here's a
question from Lam but I think about a
kid that can make almost any car fully
soft driving I think a kid is a good
idea the thing to worry about in the kid
case is it's actually not that easy to
be the good kid
many many cars use for example a
hydraulic steering booster where you
have a liquid being pushed in the system
to assist you in steering positions or
many cars use hydraulic brakes and to
interface with those you have to mess
around with kind of hydraulic systems
when we build a car here at Udacity
we use brands like fort or Lincoln who
have a relatively simple steering
interfaces all electric so you can just
snip some wire as effectively and and
and and finally your own digital message
and but it makes it much easier much
safer if you ask me what's gonna be the
future going to be would I want to build
a kid company I would be hesitant with
the kid company because likely you can
only build a kit for a certain type
vehicle maybe a Honda CRV or something
it'd be very hard to build a kit for
every vehicle and then on top of it you
need to then kind of convince people
that your kid is safe enough for all
these cars and
they have walked through the integration
to some extent is actually easier if you
focus on just one car and then the more
likely model would be that either uses
cause a taxi and buy many of those and
deploy them or try to sell this cause of
work with the OEMs and sell these cars
ready to end consumers also quite
frankly cast turn on every 10 years
right so in ten years from now people
that have a new car in average and maybe
if it takes another two or three years
to get the technology working than ten
years to know anybody buying a car gets
and septum--ah car automatically they'll
be great it's a question from Chris if
you were bidding jr. now what would you
do differently not Stanley about Junior
obviously in juniors case for those of
you have a long history memory Junior
about ten years ago 2007 participated
the urban challenge won second prize not
first prize I was distracted about
speeding up Street View at Google at the
time and the reason why I won second
prize is we had a software bug whole
bunch of DEET force that cost us a lot
of time I would probably debug this
offer a bit more in Stanley maybe
accomplishes we could have software
freeze a month before the race and then
we were able to eliminate four or five
major bugs just in testing in junior we
weren't quite as disciplined we had the
software modified pretty much the day
off and that unfortunately cost was the
first place but we also had amazing
competition to be honest and Connie
Mills was a great place and had very
strong people Chris Urmson was was
really really strong but in total I
think what we but we kind of originated
back in the day was the use of machine
learning and it wasn't quite as
grandiose as deep learning today but
both Stanley and jr. had a massive
machine learning component and at the
time we were about the only ones doing
it today even past my googa days here at
Udacity
but I find us that deep learning is just
incredibly powerful so if I were to do
it again I would probably toss out a lot
of the geometric stuff and really move
much deeper into machine learning as a
way to make the car drive better and and
do much much more of that here's a
question from Ashraf a really good
question is there safety criteria for
self-driving cars
determines when technology is ready for
the public I am tempted to say no even
though there's norms there's an Izone
norm wit and specifies how we have to
develop software called ISO 26262 that
if you follow it you know you have a
certain assurance and the quality of
your software development process but
it's not a sure install the Dakar is
actually safe my take on this is we
still have to develop good metrics for
safety part of those will require
extensive testing and you can help us
actually as a student and an RV program
think about this and brainstorm and do
products in the space one is extensive
testing we just statistically sure
prevent I know a million miles and the
many mines didn't crash this is what it
is Google the segment's also things like
cybersecurity like is it safe towards
hackers that were breaking with the
system and we've recently seen that even
regular cars can be hacked and there's
been instances where academic research
has proved that you can go into a
commercial vehicle and disable the
brakes which is very very dangerous
that ability to hack into systems will
obviously be reverse with self-driving
cars because there's a much more bigger
software interface so one thing that we
have to prove to ourselves is that it's
the early days you're gonna join
something it's very new you're gonna
learn something it's you been VAP a
pioneer of this field and as a result
many of these questions have mean
answers
shots that means that copies will hire
people to answer those questions anyway
join us question my Samuel do you think
self-driving vehicles are more likely to
lead to more right sharing or more
individual transport they have a very
clear answer I believe the future
offices right sharing just imagine the
following you have a car that you want
to get you go to your phone and you get
on your diddy app and and you push a
button and up comes an unmanned
empty car driving to you and you hop
inside you might be the driver yourself
or you might just be driven around by it
that means that we can reduce the number
of cars needed and have much better car
utilization I did a lot of math on this
one and relative to the costs of an
uberx you can expect a cost reduction
between
sixty and eighty percent it's a lot to
be das a third of the cost so if you
currently in New York and the average
uber fears about $10 or $12 say $12 then
you would get the same ride for about $4
that is cheaper than the bus turns out
it's a big inflection point and I think
costs matter a lot in this field by
getting rid of the driver which costs a
lot of money you make transportation
really cheap so in that sense I envision
this future where the car is just
utility a car today your car is being
used some like three percent of the
lifetime in park 97 percent my car right
now is parked for the waist in the
future cars might be able to operate 50
percent of the time or so as a result be
10 times as efficient in serving people
so we not only tempers on the cars and
that means we have a complete change of
cities of that we know parking garages
you can drop yourself often in your
favorite office you can even go around
drunk and I think that vision requires
ride-sharing as the course I would put
my mother on the ride sharing that on to
owner-operators cars but who knows I am
from hosi thank you for making the
barrier to entry 2004 the US Dollars and
a PC and an internet connection this is
mind-blowing thank you for saying
sometimes people respond different to
this how can we lower the barrier to
entry even more I wish we couldn't we
could do this without having any money
obviously but we've worked really really
hard to get to 2004 and $1 and it's a
small sliver of what you paid any u.s.
research university it's still a very
high and barrier to many people because
there's a lot of money and I wish we
could do it for free but I can tell you
the services you're going to get the
personalized feedback your mentor the
information the content you get and the
products
hopefully make it worth your 2400 we
know we know it's a lot of money for you
it's a lot of money for me too
so we try to do a very very best job
here Udacity is mission is to
democratize education I have the
privilege to be a professor at Stanford
and before Carnegie Mellon
and as a result I had the privilege to
partake in amazing education and that is
a privilege of very very few people in
the United States the private sense of
the best universities in the world but
we often forget that this system is only
accessible to a small number of people
we are extremely proud that something
like the self economy be prom can reach
anyone the world that people have
internet connectivity and why it is
still expensive in many ways to many
people at least now we can go to the
Middle East we can go to Africa to South
America to China to India to Indonesia
and really help people get what we
consider the best education on the
planet so help us fulfill this mission
spread the word come to us apply enroll
help us improve critique give us
negative feedback if need be so we can
become better but make this motion of
making education available become part
of the movement the reason why you
should become part dogmas for yourself
to find a better job of course but also
I firmly believe if we can bring good
high qualification to everybody in the
work within Internet connectivity then
we can really help the world doubles its
GDP I think there's many many super
talented people in places they currently
have no access and you might be one of
them
and Udacity wants to change this so I
want to thank you for listening to me I
want to encourage you to apply the
application deadline is actually this
Monday at midnight Pacific time so it's
very very soon and get in and then I'd
like honestly explore the beauties of a
technology that is just really really
amazing I've been spending last twelve
years of my life and self-driving cars I
wouldn't want to miss a single second I
hope it'll be the same for you
you